[Music]
[Music]
staying in line with the the overall
goal of the show which is to a farm and
acquaint a beginner to intermediate
players you know between the in the six
to twelve hundred usdf rating range with
basic tactical ideas but also some of
the other ideas namely positional ideas
that go into playing a chess game
unfortunately even though some of the
claims that tactics is ninety nine
percent of chess there's arguably a
little bit more to it than just tactics
namely we need to learn and learn how to
apply a lot of different positional
principles namely controlling the center
developing rapidly creating weaknesses
avoiding weaknesses once a weakness has
been created developing a plan around
that and sticking to it so that's more
or less going to be the theme of today's
tactics time I we're just going to go
over one game we're going to go over a
game between Elijah Williams and Howard
Staunton that was played in 1851 so a
little while ago not necessarily a
modern game I played in the Romantic era
but just doesn't necessarily fit fit the
bill of it it's played in the spirit of
many romantic games in as much as II
Flores play it's met with c5 but then we
start to become all too painfully aware
of the fact that this is being played
way before opening theory right he happy
yet canwest making a face who would play
F war against be 50 as i was looking at
this is danny earlier and you yet to
play nice III um if you want to get into
the Grand Prix because you can just
black and break with d5 here and get a
decent game going okay all the more
reason for me to pick this game it's not
you know there's no established theory
that we're really going off of only the
board and positional considerations to
help
evaluate and assess the plans made by
the players on both sides so so far
pretty basic stuff developing minor
pieces controlling the center with pond
still controlling the center with ponds
and now we see white come up with a plan
and begin to commit to it he's got a
little bit of a threat here on note and
I'm not being sarcastic it's a tiny one
but it's one that that can be
undervalued at times and what wide is
threatening to do here guys is capture
on g6 why would that be a threat anybody
sort connectives it does that capture
threaten to create any positional
weaknesses maybe an undesirable paw
information doubled pawns on the C file
yes I think yes exactly which doesn't
seem like the greatest of plans
especially not it's not not in the
Sicilian so we're going to see white
come up with this plan and stick to it
and we'll see them if he makes it work
black arguably isn't really taking the
plan too seriously he just wants to see
an keto his dark squared Bishop so he
played his t6 in order to do that and
white pull this through on this plane
captures on g6 forcing doubled pawns
creating that week's e5 square which is
more or less going to be the theme
throughout the game we're going to see
the kind of problems that arise for
black by allowing the sweetness to be
created and how white goes about trying
to convert that an attack on this
weakness into a winning advantage and
then convert that winning advantage into
an actual win two options for or two
possible ways that why can continue with
his plan okay he created the weakness he
wants to fix the weakness when we've
created a weakness on the board we want
to fix it any suggestions to how we
might go about fixing the weakness
I agree and I think we put it the engine
might like Queenie to a little bit more
because it's flexible and it doesn't
create the backward deep on and it just
makes more sense uh but I liked this
because again he's sticking to his plan
he's created that weakness on c5 and for
better or worse he's just going to
create this bind on d5 with the fee for
something that you typically see after
the deep on has been exchanged on d4 for
the fee pond on that's when you see this
kind of when you're more likely to see
this kind of bind set up with bonds on
e5 and e4 for white like we see it here
with the deep on not you know still on
its home square both sides continue
developing and again with the ideas
keeping that weakness of permanent
weakness it's like to move but I want
you guys to pass the move and pretend as
if it were black to move what would lack
want to play here in order to not have
to worry about that c5 weakness what do
you think yeah defo just you want to
break immediately oh yeah d 5 is
ultimately the goal unfortunately in
this particular position I believe that
d5 would still yeah it would lose the
pond but but my overall my overarching
point would be that it would still leave
c5 undefended him if we're black can
move and her and his only priority were
to defend that fee fie upon how am I how
might he go about doing that
looking for a move this offense this
pawn d 6 right there is a bishop movies
but d 6 looks reasonable since we
haven't since we haven't moved that g6
that deep on yet so if we wanted to stop
black from doing that well what might we
play with white I'm sorry c5
preventing v6 now look at it closely
because a lot of people are you know as
well as I showed this game around the
club many people you know close to us
and strengthen you know they want to ask
immediately are you sure that that
really prevents d6 and it's worth asking
uh and if you were to play g6 here you
more or less be safe we'd be able to go
with a similar idea to the one that you
just suggested it and then that Queenie
five is the saving grace they're pretty
cool right pretty cool so the site the
side moral of that story is concrete
calculation pays healthy dividends but a
lot of these decisions are not being
made with calculation and more on
positional considerations all right
which I'm hoping is it going to provide
a nice healthy contrast to the morphe
game and some of the other kind of one
sided games that we've been looking at
where it's someone just getting crushed
because they have no positional
understanding I so and we've got a cool
tactical player tactical finish at the
end to a reward us for slogging through
this okay right age 60 he develops a
piece 97 may have may have been a better
choice here but he wants to either way
he want he wants to get get that night
on f5 why continues to develop logically
not trying to press or doing crazy
there's no no good pawn lever or a pawn
break meaning no move that we can make
with a pond putting it you know
attacking another which would cause a
favorable change in the position for us
so we just keep developing our pieces
and putting on the squares where they
look best now I know if I had black here
I would be terrified of that night on on
e4 that guy's a monster here and after
its black to move but white is
threatening here after 94 is G for
kicking the night away and then playing
that tasty check on d6 ok removing the
threat getting the king so now the idea
of G for taking the night away and 96
doesn't quite have as much force to it
you'll get your night on d6 where but
you may be able to be dislodged by the
dark squared bishop at one point but
you're not going to have the benefit of
keeping the King in the center that you
would have had in the previous line so
he doesn't put it a night on d6 he just
keeps improving his position please d3
finally creating a little room for the
his dark squared bishop if need be and
black beans he's being clever making use
of the file that he was allowed that he
allows white to open was move 5 Bishop
takes c6 doesn't have too much to worry
about just following a lot of the
principles and guidelines that we've
been familiarizing ourselves with over
the past few weeks castles early he's
got a nice solid grip on the center and
almost all of his miners with the
exception of the dark squared bishop
have been developed so White's looking
ok that g5 gets played here on drea and
now we're going to see whether or not it
was premature or well-timed
and for those of you curious ed is a
line here too I probably might be a
little bit a little bit better but I'm
not going I'm not going to be angry at
Elijah Williams for playing 93 here you
get still playable but it does allow
black the option of closing the center
with D 5 D for at any point which makes
looks annoying to those right Ken does
that look annoying Yeah right it would
appear that it he's kind of eliminating
his weakness but you're going to see
some clever ways that white still still
manages to hammer away as he five even
though d 4 is allowed ah but again
maneuvering and just slowly improving
your position so now I'm speeding
through it so this the speaks to your
point here can see 5 you know d4 hasn't
been played but you know he's threat you
still threatening d4 but by playing be
three no this is a threat aimed at c5
can you believe that on if it were wide
to move here this is what he wants to
play something like this and yet no
matter where he goes you're going to no
matter where the Queen goes take a
square but I mean I'm going to pick and
just getting driven away um and you're
going to pick up that corner fair enough
so be three looks like just a quiet move
maybe just reinforcing c4 but it's also
played with the intent of having giving
the night sun protection so that you can
attack c5 and the Queen simultaneously
so b3 threatening 9 a-4 which would be
attacking the Queen you respond to that
by putting the Queen on c7 removing that
threat and we just keep hammering away
at the original weakness which we
created c5
okay reinforcing our King safety a
little bit just continuing to play chess
now have you put this in the computer
here why just finally starting to
probably get an advantage but I ok so h5
is a neat little idea hear it crack it
open defending it bring into the
queenside night over to the king size
but kind of tempting him into playing d
for enclosing the position which I you
know I personally would not not like but
why it's okay with it and it's worth
noting here that although there are no
immediate threats in the position I mean
most of us speak up now have you
disagree with me but I would I would I
would prefer white here um and just
optically I just count how many
attacking pieces I you know I have
versus his on the King side I and I'm
feeling pretty good about my chances
even though there are no concrete lines
that I see before but here black makes
it easy for us alright he opens the line
of attack against the king and we
started this this lecture this lesson by
discussing a you know the downside are
the disadvantages to having doubled
pawns sometimes by allowing doubled
pawns we create attacking lines so it's
not so cut and dry right sometimes
they're okay sometimes there's
compensation that we can that we can
reap the night at for gets play here
with the idea of threatening taking GH
with night on f4 then you're threatening
yeah so we put this here and now we're
we're threatening capturing here right
because we've got three attackers on and
two defenders on
there's the pawn of the third
what is he trying to do okay right yeah
goodbye setting up a battery on the
light square yeah yeah cool okay and he
wants to put her whoa not there but here
can you see why he would want to put her
there yep so that on the next move
beeping put her there and say I win yeah
why doesn't seem too worried though he's
created open S&H filed his Peter's are
more active he's got more space he
defends against the threat while
creating some more threads so now no
checkmate on the square so we have an
attacking piece on an open file aimed in
the direction of your king important
stuff getting another piece ready to
bring you into the attack so this little
Brook lift with the idea of putting him
on the H file at some point lashing out
sometimes when we're when we're winning
and we have a crushing position the
hardest part is to just cool be
navigator against your opponent lashing
out right doing crazy stuff and not
getting kind of not not allowing
yourself to be swindled or tricked um f5
doesn't scare him it just says okay I'm
going to get more space and create a
passed pawn I think most of us would
play GF here and this this is the
sequence that you know made me feel
somewhat justified in putting this in a
in a lecture titled tactics time so I
want to let you guys look at this for a
while and you at home think about it to
what would you play with light here
and why Queen takes age 7 all right
pause how about you did you see it all
right um so there yeah that's the first
line that you give us each and then
actually 98 like 97 after that so yeah I
can get 797 yeah put them off and we
still have yet still have a fair amount
of work to do but it's not really i mean
yeah you're still crushing it I'd be
probably most moves in this position are
our killer um but yeah Elijah Williams
had an interesting idea he just played
night takes g6 with the idea of
recapturing on h2 with the rook rook
takes Queen which will happen then the
brook where we capture and there will
still be threats very similar to those
in the line that we just looked at make
sense I I agree I can without yet
looking at it too closely um so that is
what gets played black you know
rightfully so is a bit suspicious of
this and does not does not capture the
Queen immediately but decides to capture
on f6 doing a few different things but
you know this at the very least you know
on a good day maybe he's dreaming about
something like this um maybe if they
know the book doesn't recapture we know
who really knows what what he's thinking
all right so we better make sure that we
know what we're doing right
okay let's force a mate who's going to
shout out that force mate and show me
what a tactical wizard they r s7 king g
7i think that may be stronger now it's a
little more forcing right a little more
forcing where is he going you're going
home to cry you're going to have seven
if it gets a notation right so you did
good you won yeah night what night what
five or maybe I just need to clean my
ears Oh F nighy five yeah yeah I may
have misheard you yeah I thought you
said d5 yeah it is painful that's a
painful-looking me and that's definitely
a tactical finish but one that only
happened after a heat heat I hope you
guys enjoyed that hit like share and
subscribe at home and see you guys next
week
[Music]
Oh
[Music]